we are live now
excellent well i'd like to say a big
welcome then to everybody
and thank you all for attending this
year's fight home council of europe
webinar to introduce the
fiber market panorama report for 2021
my name is eric joyce and i'm proud to
be both a board member of the vibrant
home council of europe while also being
the chair of the market intelligence
working committee
which is made up of our member
organizations with their representatives
devoting time and energy into research
validate and validation
of our various reports released
throughout the year
for those who are not familiar with the
market panorama report it's a yearly
look into the progress europe is making
towards a full fiber future
it forms today part one of two major
releases from our working group
where we take a snapshot in time
september of the previous year
so in this case september 2020
and we paint a picture of how each
country is progressing
across europe is progressing in areas
such as fibre homes past
and actual active subscribers of fibre
services
we also take a look at some of the
year-on-year trends and we'll point out
other areas of great progress signs of
new progress
on the horizon along with a look at some
of the headwinds that we need to
navigate
through to reach our goals we also take
a look at some qualitative outcomes of
that progress
and what real life impact this can make
in the home
we will couple this with the second part
of this report the market forecast
at the fiber to the home virtual
conferences in september
where we look more at future trends and
make predictions
while expanding somewhat on the existing
report to look at some of the challenges
in getting fiber to for example
underserved areas and we also intend to
welcome back the global ranking which
has been absent for the last couple of
years
so we'll see that at the second part in
in september
but back to today i'm delighted to
introduce roland montagne from our
partner
in this report idate rolon is a
principal analyst for broadband and ftdx
as well as the director for networks and
smart territories practice at idate
roland is responsible for all research
activities for the broadband and fiber
fields
at idate and he and his team have been
central to our market panorama research
for many years
so before i pass the baton to roll on to
take us through this year's market
market panorama report for 2021 i'd like
to highlight that we'll have a couple of
poll questions to keep you on your toes
two two two polls in this section and we
ask many of you to
participate as possible when they when
they do pop up
and likewise there is a question panel
where you're free to submit questions to
to roll on myself and we'll do our best
to
answer as many as we can in the time
remaining or follow up with you
with you after birth afterwards so with
that uh roll on i'll ask you to update
us
all on how europe is progressing to our
full fiber future
thank you very much eric for your kind
introduction
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen it's
my true pleasure to deliver you the
update of ftth
market panorama in europe in this
webinar despite
i would have preferred to see you live
but i'm sure uh
he would be for a near future
so this is the agenda of the
presentation of today
i will come back on how we gather this
data
we will go for general overview and main
trends
for europe concerning fiber to the home
uh
we will try to determine who is leading
the race toward full fiber with the pool
that will be addressed at this stage
european ranking will be delivered also
and then we will go with some key
conclusion
so what is the study background for this
panorama we are
handling yearly for the ftth council
europe since 2004
it provided indeed a complete summary of
the status of ftth
in europe and it is measured each year
september
so for this panorama the measurement is
on for september
2020. the scope geographical scope of
analysis is covering 39 countries
and we try for each project to deliver
key parameters such as
the status of homes past subscribers but
also
technical choice and also in investment
or regulatory
uh situation in the country our
methodology
is clearly button-up approach of course
there is some desk research at the
beginning of the exercise
but then we go with direct contact with
the leading players
involved in ftth rollout and of course
we are also extensive exchange
with the members of the ftth
consular europe to adjust the data and
the results here
are both quantitative and qualitative
given the market status per project and
also
at the level of the country
first it is important to have in mind
what are the key definitions for our
panorama
three key definitions first is homspast
where here we are measuring
um the homes where
the fiber is arriving in a service area
and the definition excludes a premises
that cannot be connected without further
installation or substantial fiber plant
to reach the subscriber location
socket is here defined
like connection point of a single fiber
single provider inside or outside the
premises
and here we know that it's possibility
there is a possibility to have a
multiply socket in the location so here
we are not taking it
into account the overlap that is taking
into account of course
on the hub's past measurement finally
the subscribers
are the premises of the homes we are
paying for
a fiber connection so we are connected
uh to a network
what is the general overview and main
trends
in this part two of the presentation
well here you have the key figures for
this edition
of the panorama
if we look ft hftb
fiber to the home of fiber to the
building that it is measured
in line with the sdga definition we are
measuring here in her u-39
a u-39 composition
is on one side a u-27 plus united
kingdom
but also four cis countries
and other countries such as iceland
israel
or norway or switzerland or turkey for
example
the total in terms of subscribers
is 82 million to be compared
to 183 million
ftthb homes past
we have to point out the growth i will
come back on this
more in detail but the growth here on
the subscriber
base it's plus 17
year to year and for the homes past it's
12
a little bit less demonstrating that the
market is totally more oriented
on the commercialization of this fiber
to the home
also important to be noticed is the
take-up plate
it is the ratio subscribers on homes
past
well there is a progression on a u-27
plus
uk 46.9 it's
up 3.6 percent also a progression less
than 2 percent
for u49 39 and nearly
45 percent coverage rate
also which is the ratio homes passed on
total homes
is progressing at the level of u27 plus
uk
with a plus 4.4 at
43.8 and it's also a progression less
but it is
for u49 more than 52 percent
we know that especially with the
pandemic
crisis teleworking
has really been developed in europe with
no choice
and for this there is a need for a
robust
connectivity so we have seen an
acceleration
in europe of the subscription level
uh also a u-27 plus uk countries
account for more than 56 percent of the
total ftth
subscription this is an increase
compared to last year
of 2019.
also with more that
98 million home past it means
there are more than half 54 of those
deployment
are performed inside 20 u27
plus uk so you can see here the steady
growth
with this acceleration since
last year in eu 39 in terms of
subscribers
and also in au 27 plus uk
and the same uh i i would say at the
level of homes past
uh in a u-27 processor k and u-49
we also looking here in the panorama
what are the categories of players
deploying a fiber to the home we have
pointed out
in this panorama around 400 ftthb
initiative at september last year
you can see on the right side of the
slide
the breakdown in terms of ftth home pass
in the top five
european countries in terms of volume
number one
being russia nearly 50 million france
more than 21 million spain
nearly 16 million ukraine
below 12 million and italy 11 million
you can see also especially
from september 2019
to september 2020
that 39 percent of connect home are
passed
by incumbent versus 41
in 2019 so it shows that as net
increased their part of market share in
one year
also municipalities and utilities
are a kind of category covering
many remote and isolated areas
further enhanced with public fund and
incentive and they represent
september last year four percent of the
homes passed
before going to this question who is
leading
the race toward full fiber we have a
pool here eric
yes indeed let me just kick off this
poll here one moment
and i'm going to launch this and the
question is going to be
which country in the eu 39 so all 39
countries that form
uh the the basis of the report has
topped the homes past
growth chart in absolute numbers over
the past year
so i've gone ahead and launched that we
have about 90 seconds
if you can go ahead and make your guess
make your make your estimate
based on this list here and we'll check
and see
how those results are looking
quite interesting at the moment
a good mix of responses
and i'll give it another 30 seconds
unless activity does slow down we seem
to have a lot of votes in already which
is great
a few more votes for spain going in at
the last minute
all right let me just i'm going to go
ahead and screenshot this and just make
sure
if i hit close here
uh it's not and i'll share the results
so we had france here being the uh
the top choice with 31 percent of people
choosing france
united kingdom in second with 25 and
spain
just coming behind with with 24 with
germany and
poland then making up fourth and fifth
place in in in our
in our poll so roland i'm going to close
this and if you can take us to the
actual
leaderboard and let us know who actually
stole that top spot
so france uk and spain let's see the
results
so the results are pointed out in terms
of
homes past and the
the growth uh are here presenting uh
presented in the in the slide first you
can see
on the right side of this slide
um the uh the fastest market
uh in terms of percentage uh
of course it depends on the starting
point uh
in terms of quantitative
volume so you see that in terms of
percentage belgium is number one
followed by germany uk
also ireland
being being there and in terms of volume
uh well you see
this is france being number one with
plus 4.6 million new homes passed
in one year followed by italy
plus 2.8 million in terms of
homes past and followed by
germany with plus 2.7 million
home past the uk here is number four
in this ranking with
plus 1.7 million
homes passed
if we look at the same ranking at u-39
in terms of trump's past of course here
russia is leading the league
closer to 48 million
homes passed and then
we have also a newcomer in the in the
ranking here
in terms of volume it's turkey at the
fifth place
uh with a growth in one year of plus one
two million
on past and then the top four is not
changed compared to a u27
in terms of a new on past and volume
total
we also looking at the coverage
uh of course in this panorama this is
the ratio
homes passed on total homes you see here
the result for you 27 of you
plus uk so we can say that today we are
halfway
halfway there i would say indeed
here 14 up 28
upon upon 28 countries are exceeding
50 percent of total homes passed with
a full fiber
you see after the result
in terms of coverage
this time in eu 39
here we have 20 countries
that have more than 50 of total homes
with full fiber so you can see
the leaders in terms of coverage like
from belarus latvia or iceland spain
is also well positioned you see
also the average for a u39
more than 52 percent and the average for
you to do
27 plus uk less than
44 percent
it's also quite interesting to see this
on the map
uh this is the summary map here
uh with the different i would say
categories
of countries in terms of coverage
well we see that coverage
are historically quite high in the north
of europe
and this is here verify in the pioneer
market
like sweden with more than 80 percent
in terms of coverage or iceland 90
it is also very high in the south part
of europe
with the leaders in terms of deployment
over there portugal
with 83 percent of spain 88
then we have friends with 73 percent
in terms of homes covered italy
is halfway i would say we 41
poland also more than 40 percent and
then we have the two
more native market uh i would say
like the uk and germany
close to 15
we are also measuring in this panorama
the socket deployed i don't come back
here
in the definition so it's not taking
into account
overlap this is here what's happening
in u27 plus uk
the same you have on the right side
the growth in terms of the percentage of
the market
and the total in terms of
homes socket sorry socket and deployed
so here again uh the the top market
of france uh spain uh
and italy in the in the top three
followed
uh by uh germany and
in the uk
this was on a u-27 plus uk
we have the same uh picture for socket
deployed on au
39 so here
uh the same you have on the right side
of the slide the fastest growing market
and
things are nearly unchanged
here with maybe the main change being
russia being at the third
place in terms of volume or also
serbia being with a strong growth
in terms of a socket deployed
after talking about the deployment it's
important of course to see
the success of commercialization of
fiber
to the home we have here
the ftt hp subscribers
and u27 plus uk
ranking the same on the right side
we have the growth in terms of the
volume
you see here the presence of ireland or
italy or greece
or germany or belgium and
in terms of volume in one year
again france is representing
the fastest number the highest number of
new subscribers in one year
plus 2.8 million followed
by spain plus 1.4
[Music]
million and followed by
germany with plus
less than plus 700 000
in this in this market
if we look at the same subscriber
ratio looking this time
on ou 39 well
you see a new commerce here in terms of
the fastest growing market
like israel for for example being here
at plus 64 percent
and you see also in terms of the
volume france is still number one
plus 2.8 million best russia
with plus 1.7 million uh it's
number two in volume here and we have
also
uh the the coming of turkey with more
than seven hundred thousand
new subscribers in in one year
this um indicator is quite important
also we call this the take-up rate
it is measuring the commercial success
indeed it is the ratio home passed
over household
the take-up rate for ou27 plus uk
has seen a production close to
47 percent also probation for u49
close to 45 percent
and here uh you see um
this take-up uh positioning
well uh again uh
in the north uh the success
is there with iceland close to
uh 80 the success
also is here in
spain with the 71
percent uh in the others country
france including or the uk or germany
or italy there is competition
with other platforms for example
vdsl and cable in the uk
or or germany still
performing adsl also in france
and the same in italy so there is still
a work here for the deployers of fiber
to the home
to promote the benefit of ftth
and to enhance this ratio
of a tick-up rate
this year uh as a new
action we have decided also to do
a little focus on microstates
we are not present in the european
ranking
because of the minimum
household in one country to be part
of the european ranking but
we have pointed out here four
microstates
where fiber to the home is progress
with good ratios um
the champ i would say uh in these
four micro states is andorra
uh with uh uh nearly uh 100
of the country covered and penetration
rate
fiber subscribers on total household
of more than 80 percent um
license time also
is doing a good performance with close
to 70 percent
of the homes being already
passed with fiber
penetration rate is below
50 percent in niche time
um monaco uh is doing well
uh in terms of um uh
homes past and the ratio of coverage
sixty percent but the commercial success
is not really here today because of
competition with other platforms
so so there is here clearly a point of
progress concerning fiber with only
three percent of the household being
subscribing
subscribing to fiber to the home finally
san marino is representing
56 percent in terms of coverage
and a little bit less of 50
in terms of penetration right so it was
a the premiere
for this microstate progress and we will
continue
uh to follow the progress in those
microstates
for the coming panorama
also here a new approach coming from the
the market committee
we try here to overlap
the fiber penetration alongside
with the oclock global index looking at
the fixed
upload bandwidth on one side and also
alongside the ocular
global index talking about
latency so we know
that full fiber connectivity
is really designed at the residential
stage
to support the increase in demand
of demanding intensive bandwidth
services such as a
4k tv 4k grtv and a car
coming this is also the good medium
for enabling working from home and we
know that
this has been a really
an increase of working for home of
course with the
current covet pandemic
and video conferencing like you are
doing today
has been also one of the killer app of
this
period so on the
left side of this slide
you see the correlation
quite clear between the fixed
upload bandwidth and the
fiber penetration you see
clearly this decrease of fiber
fixed upload bandwidth
in countries where penetration is quite
low
this is quite clear on the right side
of this slide another we know benefit
of fiber of course is to be the best
medium to deliver short latency
and this is verifying when we are
looking
at this latency global index by ocla
the same you we can see that the latin
thing is quite low
where the penetration of fiber is quite
high
and inversely where the penetration rate
is quite low then the latency
is growing in terms of of a millisecond
more than 30
milliseconds so a very interesting slide
i believe to really demonstrate
in terms of a bandwidth and in terms of
latency
what are the main benefits to have a
fiber to the home connection
fourth part of the presentation uh will
be
uh to present you uh the european
ranking of september 2020 waiting for
the global ranking as eric was saying
uh for the september uh fth council
europe
conference this european
ranking is measuring the penetration
rate
of european countries the penetration
rate
is the ratio subscribers on total
households
in the country we also distinguish here
the technology being a fiber to the home
directly in blue and fiber to the
building and stopping at the basement
of the building so the champion
here in europe is again iceland
with the 70.7 percent and very close we
have a belarus
more than 70 percent
one main economy of europe is number
three
spain with more than 62 percent
follow by sweden we have russia
at more than 40 percent with a high
proportion of fiber to the building
france is a 35
and then we see um the average
of a u27 plus uk
more than a 20
percent and at the bottom of this
ranking
we can point out countries
such as italy less than six percent
of germany less than five percent or the
uk
uh less than four percent or
again austria two percent or belgium a
little bit
more than than one percent or he had the
economy with at least
125 percent thousand in terms of uh
household
but i think it's also time here for a
new pool
eric indeed yeah so the on the next
slide we're going to show you something
um which we haven't included before so
now that we've crossed
that magic 50 threshold when it comes to
homes past in europe
we wanted to start focusing a little bit
a little bit more on what's left
rather than what's what's been
accomplished both are very important
um but one thing that this this slide
showed us
at the top was that there's still quite
a lot of work left left to be done
across
the region so we wanted to ask a
question and just get your
immediate opinions before we we we give
you the answer but
how many countries do you think make up
60 of the remaining homes left to be
connected
in the eu 27 plus uk
so here's the question here the poll is
now open
and we'll go for about 60 to 90 seconds
how many countries make up approximately
60
of the remaining homes to be connected
in the eu 27 plus uk
we've got a very even split so far
just with a slight preference for one
good voting turnout so far just almost
70 percent
of you have responded so remaining 30
we'll go another 10 seconds or so and
and see where we end up
all right so we'll go ahead now and
close that poll
with 76 percent having voted
and i'll share now those results with
you
so if the attendees today um for how
many countries make up 60
the largest number of estimates are in
and around five countries
with three four and six almost identical
with eighteen percent each and seven
taking up the last place here so i'll go
ahead and hide this now and go back to
your presentation
roll on and if you can let us know what
the real answer is
thank you eric indeed the three
countries
representing almost 60 percent of the
entire remaining homes to be passed
in the u-27 first uk or germany
uk and italy but let me
go in the detail of this slide indeed
you see here in blue what remained
to be done in terms of home past
and in pink was already
being done in terms of
homes past so you see indeed
in country like germany more than 34
million
homes have to be passed in the united
kingdom
more than 23 million in italy more than
15 million and on the other side
you see countries
that already quite advance in terms of
compassed with a large long
pink part like france
for example where only 8 million
homes remain to be passed like romania
for example
2.3 million like spain with only
2.2 million
and of course you see the other
countries with the remaining part being
quite quite low uh on the bottom of the
slide
so this shows really the dynamic uh of
the main market
uh in in europe the top three
uh are mentioned if we took the top six
countries so you had to this top three
poland
france and netherlands in here and those
countries
make up over 75 percent of the entire
remaining
homes to be passed in a u-27
plus plus uk
what are the key conclusion of this
panorama well we have seen that
we have both positive and negative
criteria
that should be considered first
there is competition with other
technology uh the first
is a the fix
wireless access and especially the
gigabit capabilities access
it is a platform that can be used
in isolated area so he can delay
fth deployment in those areas
and we believe also when millimeter
waves
will be available for 5g technology that
it will be also
the same challenge for ftth in some
areas
we have seen in some countries still
a competition with other
alternative technology we know that
caddo
when it is properly deployed with doxys
3.1 can deliver a giga
connection or cut 4.0 will also
be capable of very high capacity
bandwidth and there is also evolution of
dsl
for like gfast for example
we we know that today consumers are well
educated
especially when they are obliged to work
from home they are more and more
differentiating the quality of their
connection
and uh some misleading fiber advertising
we are not really fine with the fiber to
the curb uh
today we see uh consumers and tele
worker making the difference
with the true fiber connection
we have seen delay uh also
in some countries not all for sure but
in some
countries i have two to two years and
here uh we believe that
the government of those countries should
take action
uh to to consider
this delay and and to push
for the coordination in fiber rollout
in the country in the
potential growth
market for tomorrow for example uk and
germany we know that
the availability of skilled labor
to build out this new fiber network
is beginning to be felt in later um
2020 there is
a challenge here to provide sufficient
skilled
technician to deploy this fiber to the
home in those countries
when the peak will arrive in 21 or 22
and this is a challenge of course in the
hand of the government
of those countries to have a proper
training
for these technicians positive impacts
are there the first of them
is a the data demand and bandwidth has
intensified
especially uh in the time of
covet 19 uh in this work to the
work for home situation uh this
has accelerated in some countries
deployment or file to the home
and adoption of fabric to the home for
those new usages
we have seen also authorities national
government
uh taking new action at the national
level program uh in terms of being also
in line with the european commission
digital agenda goals for 2025 or 2013.
we know also that there is innovation in
civil engineering
and there is innovation also
in microtrenching and cable design this
can be a less a disruptive
uh way of rolling fiber in the heart of
the cities
for for example and we see
also progress in a profile cable
design for other better aesthetics
when it looks at indoor for example
a cabling
to provide a larger
coverage of fiber to the home
we have seen also partnership
and mutualized agreement from operators
especially
when filed to the home has to be
deployed outside tense areas
this partnership
from a private operator is key
to accelerate this deployment outside
the more easier i would say part of
a country when it is very dense but it
is really a necessity
to have this mutualization of investment
uh when it is especially in isolated
rural areas
finally we see also
funds being involved
in investing in fabric durham
more maybe when we are talking about
phones
more deciding to invest when
they are in front of open access
network but there is still a willingness
for those phones to invest
in this fiber technology which is
quite secure for the for the future
i would like to conclude here with
several points
first to say that fiber to the home
is reaching a new level of deployment
we have seen that fiber network are now
covering more than half of total
household in the u39
53 this is really uh an actually
an achievement for connectivity across
europe u39 is reaching 82 million
50 tier subscribers and
a u-27 plus uk is accounting for 56
percent
of the subscribers homes past are
reaching
183 million with full fiber
to be compared to 98 million
for our 27 percent key lessons
can be learned here we know
now that in many uh we call historical
corporate-based country where vdsl has
been deployed like
uk germany or italy
that now the pandemic also being there
intending to accelerate the players the
government
are looking towards full fiber
connectivity
uh in this in this country and to remind
you that there is
still some distance and then potential
uh for the
fiber industry uh with those three
countries representing sixty percent of
the remaining hops to be passed
in a u-27 plus plus uk
um national authority are more and more
involved in the digital transformation
there is a uh of course emergency
uh being
taking decision we discovered a crisis
we have seen revision of national uh
program
with relevant policy framework to
to ex promote fiber expression so
this is a good point i would say to see
a
government today helping
for fiber to the home
even for unserved
areas and sub-region where fiber to the
home
in terms of economy can be a challenge
there is to do today a concern
for these areas with the covida
pandemic they need reliable networks
like the other zone of the country and
it's a matter
of uh um success also for the economy
of a country to go and connect those
more challenging areas
finally i would like to to remind you
what are the main movers
in terms of home past in uh
in a you in europe
france has been the number one plus 4.6
italy plus 2.8 in germany
and this is a good news is now on the
under on the podium
with plus 2.7 million
so this is a a proof of big success
in terms of deployment in those
countries so this is uh
basically what i wanted to share with
you but now i give the mick to eric
and i'm quite happy to answer your
questions
thank you roland we really appreciate
the efforts you and
and the idea team have have done to help
us pull together this year's market
panorama report
um so we did get a whole bunch of
questions in um i i've answered some of
them
in the uh directly so um hopefully
everybody can see those
those questions and answers um and
there's a few more that i can probably
answer some of them myself and then i i
may deflect some of them to to roll on
um
but uh one that i see here was um
on our comparison really with the oopla
data
um so obviously we showed upload
bandwidth and we showed latency and you
could see quite clearly in those graphs
the trend across those countries and and
there was a clear benefit
accruing to those countries who have
actually rolled out an a high number of
subscribers of fiber services
and so we did get a question was there
also a correlation for download
bandwidth
um with with that penetration and the
answer is yes there
there is it's a lot less and i'll
explain why in just a moment
so the reason we included the two that
we did is they're directly impacting on
work from home
um activities um where a download
itself uh was was affected we have to
understand that a lot of the speed tests
you know really what we're what we're
doing when we get to the download speed
because some of those are so high
on docsis technologies and even vdsl or
35b technologies is that the download
speed is already
quite high at least as far as the
devices that we use
can achieve over things like wi-fi
inside the home
and so what we see is we do absolutely
see a trend
towards high fiber sites but it wasn't
quite as visible
as the upload data and the latency data
so we we picked those
to um to highlight the difference that
we saw
um another question we had here uh let
me see
you may have actually covered this on
the sockets slide roll on so i'll i'll
call this out um
do you have an idea of the percentage of
over build in the
eu 27 plus uk and the eu 39 regions
so you know how many countries have um
you know typically single deployments to
each home
and in how many countries is there
obvious overbuild
well there is um some countries or where
overbuild
is quite is quite high
[Music]
the case of spain for example uh is
there
uh the case of france also but it is a
different of a bill because it's
stopping uh at the point of
utilization uh i i would say there is
also some other build
in some eastern parts of europe
and it can be also another build
appearing
in native market in the uk for example
have in mind that in the city of
cambridge
you can have access at the same point to
a three or four
atth operators so
um this is happening in these
in these countries
it is happening mainly in
dense areas where private investment
is key and where
some telcosa are convinced that you have
to own your your
your own network to address the the
the residential but of course this is
not the case
uh even in those countries when you are
going
outside financed areas
okay another question here was really
just one for clarification and we were
asked regarding
so obviously the the a lot of the
numbers we show are for fiber to the
home but also fiber to the building
and of course fiber to the curb is
completely excluded from any of the
numbers that we're showing you here
today
and so there was a question about the
technologies that are considered
for the last drop in an fttb scenario
well in the fttb scenario
it really depends uh on
what's available um in the
in the building most of the time in
building your different
technologies in some eastern country it
can be a coax
for the for the last uh portion of the
of the building
it can be also copper in other case so
this is really
taking into account the heritage in
terms of
of technology being deployed inside the
ndus
in each country so it is quite variable
i would say from one country to another
okay there's a couple of questions kind
of around the topic
of open networks so this is really where
countries may be deploying a
single infrastructure network and then
having that wholesale retail
environment i guess more more tightly
regulated
do you have any i guess comments on on
on europe and any countries in general
that might be might be going down that
route
in particular well
um the the pioneer i would say in terms
of
open access network for europe has been
a country like sweden
for example when the first deployment
already uh
he was involved in open access network
the city of stockholm is an example or
also the municipality the statsnet
in europe then there is the
the the planned very high speed
broadband in france
where in france nearly each of the 100
department
are deciding to set up a consortium to
establish and operate
an open access network but
the country has been divided by the
the private investment growing uh in
cities neither area
and the open access network being
deployed
in the department outside those high
dense
idents areas we see also
some examples in poland today of
open access network being proposed
for some area so this is really
i would say um italy also uh with uh
uh the the the the example of uh
involvement of open fiber uh this is
really
uh today
a strategic approach quite common
i would say in europe
where you want to push
fiber all out outside of dense areas
okay there's a few questions coming in
talking about um
what well what equipment vendors but
i'll i'll close that for a minute and
say what what technology types are being
chosen for fiber to the home deployment
and i can maybe give my view first and
and and roll on maybe you can chime in
afterwards because i know you have have
these details in the report
and you know a lot of countries have
already deployed a more of a
point-to-point architecture
um over the over the previous years
there's there's certainly some
advantages to
to to doing that um however we're
definitely seeing a switch
towards more pond-like technologies
we're taking more advantage of a passive
optical distribution network and
especially now as there's a
kind of a larger focus on um lower
energy consumption
and less active equipment in the field
we're seeing a lot of those
point-to-point operators start to
migrate towards
towards pawn technology um especially
now that those speeds have increased
past g
pawn to to 10 gig pawn and and future
versions of pawn now being standardized
and i think that's my my own view of it
but i roll onto any
some figures maybe you can give us and
and some experience
over what that transition has been like
over the last couple of years
no i completely share your view uh eric
at the beginning of the fiber
adventure i was saying we started this
panorama in 2004 so here
there was some internet point of point
deployment
in sweden for example even in france it
was happening
but more and more because of
also of the metrics of the economy of
scale
being today more in the camp of a pond
and and the deployment of massive pawn
network
has already happened in china for
example so this is driving the cost also
quite low in terms of pawn technology
and the performances also are there in
terms of
less space to be taken inside the decks
and all the family of the next next-gen
porn
arriving as you said the right ng pawn
but also
uh he is quite soon at 25 pawn or
or 50g pounds so today nearly
95 percent i would say uh of the hobbs
past
in europe uh addon on point technology
excellent thank you for that um i've
seen a question pop up a couple of times
now and it's quite topical
so i thought i'd address that as the
last as the last question was as we are
getting down to the last few minutes
um so you know we've mentioned fixed
wireless access and we've mentioned
of course advances in docsis and and
copper technologies like gfast
um you know impacting fiber roll out but
um
i guess we don't see a massive mention
of of low earth orbit systems you know
starlink
has is being deployed at the moment and
there's you know at least three or four
other
ventures offering are planning to offer
similar systems
and you know do we see that as being a
competitor to fiber
or you know a delaying factor for for
fiber
um my immediate point would be that um
you know for for for coverage and for
access of very difficult areas
you know it's it's a wonderful
technology and development and it's
providing what i would
equate to maybe an fttc type service
at best at the moment and so i don't see
it as a replacement
or a direct competitor to a full fiber
whether it be ftdh or fttb connection
um but it is a wonderful way of
connecting areas that simply cannot be
connected in
in any other way
for sure i i'm in line with you a system
like
starlink is not there today it will be
based not there today but there is a
new satellite solution involving k-band
for example
utelsat has this kind of solution being
uh
proposed for france for example since
north this year so here
this is a good solution uh to connect
with 100
megabits so it's not a negligible
zones where fiber will arrive in two
three or
four years so this is an immediate
solution
that can give a user in those areas
a better solution that what their
experience today
all right thank you for that so we've
only got about two minutes left so at
this point
um there's lots of questions we didn't
get to i apologize we will try and come
back
to you individually on that over the
next couple of days and we do have a
record of those questions
um so what i would like to do really is
um first of all say thank you to roland
for taking us through the report this
afternoon
and thank you to everybody who's sent in
a question or even participated today
and my apologies again for not getting
to to each one
and if you want you can reach out
individually you have our contact
details on this
on this slide if we do not get back to
you and we'd also
like to to say a big thank you to to our
operations team
and emilia harriet and and sergey for
managing the webinar and all of the
communications
around it this wouldn't have happened
without them and i'd like to remind
everybody that this year's five-day home
conference will again be a virtual event
taking place on september 15th and 16th
of this year
where we promise to have some
fantastically detailed discussions on
the state of fiber
with 20 expert workshops 17 conference
sessions and
over 150 leading speakers so we really
look forward to seeing you there
remotely of course this year and we
assure you that plans are in motion for
a physical event
in 2022 where we also hope to see you
all in person
thank you very much thank you bye
you